if you're broke grab this go on the bus
sit on the bus like this everybody's
gonna look at you be like yeah yeah yeah
keep laughing
come home dude take a picture
there's so much demand for professionals
for freelancers out there if you don't
have a job
and you're looking to make a full-time
income then some of these could be great
options for you that you can start
making money from today
want to be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evancar michael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the six ways to
make easy money
on the side enjoy
okay let's kick it off with way number
one sell stuff
online with garyvee i think i just
eliminated for the first time in my
career the excuse of no money
we think a lot about money and
opportunity let me tell you about an
opportunity that i can't get out of my
head this is like a big day for me
literally for
30 years i've had to like pander to that
excuse
it's over there's a website called
craigslist.com
under the sale section there's a free
section underneath that
where people list [ __ ] that they want to
get rid of don't take it
for free because most people just want
you to pick it up because it's bigger
what have you
if you happen to actually have like a
truck for like a bigger vehicle
then you are really set carry this [ __ ]
on the bus
if you're broke grab this go on the bus
sit on the bus like this everybody's
gonna look at you be like yeah
yeah keep laughing come home dude
take a picture and then you list it on
facebook marketplace the arbitrage of
the internet
we see this in retail where people buy
things in china post on amazon
15 bucks somebody's like yo i'll take
your table ding dong
yo hello here you go and you sell it
and when i think about this i can't i've
been dreaming about this for the last 72
hours by the way
the much more humble version when you've
got nothing
if you're just sitting like i need money
like all those people that were like yo
can somebody buy me garyvee's book i
can't afford it
that means you know seventeen dollars
i think it's like 300 a week if you take
your 6 p.m to 9 00 p.m
monday and tuesday picking up and then
reposting it on facebook marketplace and
then meeting people on saturday
to come to your home and grab it and
then somebody's going to say but damn
it's gonna take 40 minutes to go there
40 minutes to take on the bus
five minutes to post seven minutes i'm
like but what are you doing with your
time anyway
you're laying on the phone going on
people's accounts
who are winning saying this guy's
[ __ ] because that's what you're
doing with your time
when you're losing it's crazy to me
that the only thing that stops somebody
from winning
is education and the work ethic right i
understand that
but education comes in so many different
forms go to craigslist get free
from the free section take it and then
put on facebook marketplace and sell it
zero to a thousand steve zero to a
thousand
way number two be a beta tester with
stefan james
even if right now you've already got a
job but you're looking for a way to make
some side income
this could be great for you or if you
don't have a job and you're looking to
make a full-time income
then some of these could be great
options for you that you can start
making money from today
so with that being said let's dive right
into it okay so the first way that you
can start making money from home
is by being a beta tester a beta tester
what this means is that you get paid
for testing other companies products
services
their app and just basically giving them
feedback
you just reviewing things because these
big companies when they launch a new
product a new app a new website
they're looking for people that can test
it so you get paid
to test products websites apps all that
sort of stuff
so it's fairly simple anyone can do this
so here's one website that can allow you
to do this
i'm going to share with you a few right
now and i'll link these below
one is called usertesting.com okay so
they're
basically a website where they work with
some of the biggest companies
and if you click up here get paid to
test they have a section where you can
apply and you can sign up for it
so you can earn up to 60 dollars per
test okay so you got to visit a website
or an app
and then all you got to do is just
complete a set of tasks that they have
for you
so you complete the tasks that they have
you speak your thoughts out loud
and they pay you for that okay so again
they're just looking for feedback
and as many people as possible to
provide this feedback and to test for
them
so it says here you get paid 10 via
paypal for every
uh 20 minute video that you complete and
user testing pays you to visit websites
or apps complete a set task speak your
thoughts out loud
very very simple okay i'll link this
below so that you can check
check this one out but here's another
one called try
my ui dot com okay so similar kind of
concept
they have a section here it says get
paid to test
and they pay ten dollars for every test
that you take
okay so a typical test lasts
approximately 20 minutes
and here you can go and sign up and
start testing
things for designers and coders this is
what this website is mostly for
another great one is called
userlytics.com okay so
similar uh concept they have a tester
sign up
area here as well so if i click here
it says get paid to test websites and
apps register and earn money by
completing the short and easy form on
this page
okay interact with web or the mobile app
and you get paid by paypal
and it says you get paid five to five
dollars ten dollars fifteen twenty
dollars
or other amounts some of the projects
pay as much as ninety dollars for having
fun expressing opinions
while navigating the web so how cool is
that
way number three become an online
freelancer with dan lok
so these are income streams that you can
start part-time right you can start the
evening on the weekends that shouldn't
take away your focus
or effort or whatever you're doing now
to earn that primary source of income
does that make sense
yes sir let's say you have a job that's
making you three thousand dollars a
month what this
side hustle is designed to do is to make
you another 500
a month a thousand dollars a month it
helps to pay for your mortgage payment
it helps to pay for your car payment or
your grocery payment doesn't matter what
it is
and these are little income streams that
you can start on
the site become a freelancer i'm talking
about
video editor graphic designer writer
anyone could get started because now
there's so much demand in the
marketplace you can see it from upwork
or guru.com
there's so much demand for professionals
for freelancers out there
by developing your skill and anyone
could learn this you may take some
online courses learn how to do that
graphic design how to do their website
design or how to edit that video
with a laptop you could work from home
and you could work from anywhere and you
could do this part-time you can do this
full-time
again you do this on the weekends easy
easy income stream
anyone can do hi this is dan lok i want
to share with you a
lesson from evan carmichael's new book
build
to serve this section is about making
money from your purpose
you have to embrace that if you never
learn how to make money from your
purpose
you always end up needing a day job and
your purpose will become
a hobby if that sounds like a great life
to you
then i'm happy for you if not then you
need to figure out a money making model
that makes sense one that is consistent
one that
is significant one that can pay you so
you can quit your job and succeed
to the point where you are providing
jobs for others
and helping even more people you see
money is nothing more than a byproduct
of value creation the more people that
you serve
the more successful that you will be so
to have long-term success it's not just
built a lot or or built to sell or even
build a skill
it is built to serve and this book will
teach you
exactly how to do that way number four
engage in delivery services with nate
o'brien
utilizing a service called instacart so
this is sort of like
ubereats or grubhub but what you're
doing is you're actually delivering
groceries you're actually shopping in
the store and then delivering groceries
to somebody and you'll get paid for it
so this is actually something that
sometimes uber drivers will do this and
lyft drivers will do this but you can do
this
really almost a full-time gig by
delivering groceries to people
but you can also do this very part-time
you get to choose your own hours
the pay is pretty decent from what i've
heard you can go on a glassdoor and just
check out
the salaries on there whatnot but it's
very flexible with time and it's just
something
that i thought would be really
interesting to throw into this list
because it's definitely gonna be
something that's
more up and coming into the future as
more people order groceries online
and people deliver them to their house
well you can be one of those people who
delivers them and you don't necessarily
need a car for this
i believe you can use a bike but i'm not
entirely sure you might want to fact
check me on that
but but instacart and you know if you
don't qualify for instacart
look into ubereats or grubhub or
doordash there's so many different
services out there
in the gig economy where you can deliver
food or other types of
items way number five tutor online with
charlie chang
tutoring people over zoom and skype and
by doing this you can easily make
15 to 80 per hour this is one that i
have done
and there are many ways to go about it
first you'll actually need to think
about
what subjects you can actually
successfully tutor on and then think
about what grade levels you can actually
teach
so most of the time most people actually
prefer in-person tutoring but now is the
time where everyone
only wants online tutoring so this is
really the perfect time to actually get
into this business
and start to build up a client list
second you'll want to post a listing
onto facebook marketplace and
craigslist also post on your facebook
and other social media accounts
basically what you're going to be doing
is advertising your services
and telling people why they should use
you list the subjects you teach
the grade levels your credentials as
well as your rates
remember you don't need to drive to
their house for these sessions
so your rates should be lower than
in-person tutoring as for the pay
lower level subjects and lower level
grades typically get paid less
and then when you have the more complex
subjects and higher grade levels that's
when you actually can get paid
more for example if you can tutor people
in the sat
act or ap level classes you should
definitely be charging at least 50 60
per hour for tutoring getting the first
client is the hardest part
after that it's going to be a lot easier
as you will get referrals
and people will start to know your name
just keep advertising on these websites
keep telling people and soon enough you
will have multiple clients
personally i think that more and more
tutoring will go online after this
pandemic so now really is the perfect
time to set up your foundation for your
business
while everyone is at home teaching
people is fun and it's also rewarding
and it pays quite well so definitely
check out the side hustle
if you have good knowledge and you have
good teaching skills and way number six
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is do
affiliate marketing with graham stefan
now this next one takes a little bit
more work it's a little bit more of a
side hustle but as you can tell i love
this option
and it can be quite profitable when you
do it right and that
is here on youtube doing affiliate
marketing and the easiest way to start
doing this is through the amazon
affiliate program which pretty much
anyone can sign up for you can make
videos here on youtube reviewing your
favorite products or the things that you
use on a daily basis and then get paid a
commission anytime someone buys through
your link
as an example people always ask me what
sort of mic i use
in uh in my videos so what i can do is i
can review this mic
and i can unbox it show how it works
give examples of audio quality and post
that video on youtube
then i could put an amazon affiliate
link in the description to earn a
commission anytime someone wants to buy
it
and for every sale i'd make i'd probably
earn between 1 and 10
depending on the product now that might
not sound like a lot of money given just
how much time it takes to go and make a
video and post it and review a product
but you gotta think the more people that
see that product over time the more
money you're gonna make now the other
great thing about the amazon affiliate
program is that you'll get paid for
anything that they buy
as long as they use your link this means
if they go and use your link to go and
buy that microphone but instead they
don't buy the microphone because they
buy the nicholas cage pillowcase instead
you'll get paid on the nicholas cage
pillowcase or if people go and buy that
mic but then go and buy a whole bunch of
other stuff as well too with that order
you'll get paid on all of it in addition
to that there are so many other options
out there that pay affiliate commissions
like
robinhood the stock trading app is
another really popular one
that pays up to 500 for referrals
or weeble is a very similar one that
pays up to a thousand dollars in
referrals
there is easily thousands of different
options out there for you to pick from
but i'm
absolutely a believer that youtube is
such a great way to reach an audience
entirely for free
all organically where you can share your
thoughts and get paid for doing so
and this is something you could do at
any time of the day as much as you want
or as little as you want and the sky is
pretty much the limit
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and how are you going to
take action on it
this week when you schedule in what day
what time and what place you're going to
take action you have a 91
chance of actually following through
versus just a 35
chance if you just got motivated but
never created a specific plan and when
you share your plan publicly and have
some accountability you increase your
chances even further of
actually following through so i want to
know your single biggest takeaway and
your plan of action this week
in the comments so i can celebrate you
evan question how do you get paid in
doing what you do here what's the
business model thanks buddy
good work garvoy this is a great
question everybody wants to
cash it in make big money off of youtube
i'm gonna share
five different ways that you can do it
number one is advertising
and what most people think of
advertising is those ads that show up
you know before during after on the
videos and
you can make some money through
advertising i'm not allowed to share
how much money i make it's against the
youtube terms of policy
and i could get kicked off the program
so i don't want to do that for this
video
but you need to be in the tens of
millions of views
to to earn a decent
wage you know some industries are
different you know depending on what
you're targeting you can potentially
make more but you need to really be
tens of millions of views so if you are
creating the channel that can get that
far
then then this is a realistic goal for
you
otherwise you're gonna have to find
other ways to stand and so to give you a
sense
my channel now has two and a half
million views
just over and it took me 1500 videos
to get there now maybe you can get there
faster than me right maybe you're better
than me that's cool
you need to be able to get to that place
where you're in the tens of millions
the other option on advertising isn't
the the banner ads that you see before
and during and after the video
but it's through sponsored posts and
this is where you work with a customer a
client who
wants a video on their channel on your
channel
they want to work with you so i will
charge corporations to create videos for
them
and i don't do any hey you need to go
buy this product
because it's amazing you don't see that
on my channel because i feel like i lose
credibility you know i want to be
authentic in everything that i'm doing
but i will get hired by companies who
want me to make a video for
their blog or for their social media
campaigns and it may be hosted on their
youtube channel maybe host on my youtube
channel
but they'll use it in their campaigns
and maybe featuring a famous
entrepreneur
it may be my you know advice for
business owners and maybe answering a
question from one of their audience
but they'll pay me to come and do these
videos for them
because i have my channel because
there's been some growth and success and
i see that i'm good at what i do
so advertising is your first option
number two is patreon and patreon is new
and it's kind of taking a youtube
world by storm and uh there are some
people who are making
thousands and thousands of dollars every
month using patreon you can see my link
to my patreon page
in the description below if you click on
the support me page i'm only making like
50 bucks a month so
you know not not raking it in yet but
hey you never know
with patreon what it allows you to do is
ask your subscribers on your youtube
channel to
support you and they pay you a monthly
fee
it's usually small you know a dollar
five dollars ten dollars
and in return you can give them bonuses
so i have some bonuses that are
available on my patreon page
other people have different things it
basically
allows people to to support you in a
small way and if you have a big enough
audience then
people can give you enough money to make
this a living
it's definitely not a living for me but
if you go to the patreon home page you
can see
some of the people who are making
thousands of thousands of dollars every
month
using patreon number three is info
products and now we're really talking
because
the model here is you want to be seen as
an expert right i want to be seen as an
expert
so my focus is on entrepreneurship your
focus may be on something else maybe on
recipes it may be on
you know fitness whatever it is you're
an expert you should be an expert
entrepreneurs need to be an expert on
something you need to be one of the best
in the world
at what you do specifically once you
develop that expertise you can then
sell info products e-guides worksheets
whatever it is so for me i have my zuga
package right
it's 97 for the whole package it's 39
guides and worksheets that help you go
from an idea to building a massively
successful company
and the youtube videos help me
establish that credibility and build an
audience so at the end of all my videos
you see the logo
for zuga and that creates curiosity
people want to go look
into it and find out more and they buy
it
not because it's a in-your-face sales
letter page but because they've watched
the videos and they like what i'm all
about and they want more
and you'll find that as people watch
your videos they'll write in and say hey
garboy do you have anything you have a
book you have you have worksheets you
have something
more because i want i love what you're
doing and i want more so
info products can be your route there
number four is speaking
i speak all around the world at
conferences to help entrepreneurs to
help corporations
and a lot of the leads i get are through
youtube so
as an example i did my malaysia trip and
i asked how did you find me and i said
well we loved your youtube videos we
watched your channel
and we wanted to we said we gotta get
this guy to come and speak at our event
and they'll
they'll pay for your flight you know
when you're when you're charging these
things you want them to pay for your
flight you want them to pay for
your accommodation so your hotel you
want them to pay for your
your transfer so your taxi ride to and
from the airport
plus a speaking fee that uh is on top of
it and
as you get better and as your videos get
better as you do more speaking
then then you can build this business up
and make it something that you can live
off of
i recommend having a speaker page
to showcase your expertise and what
you're really good at
you can look at mine it's it's evan
carmichael.com speaking
and on there i have it all laid out for
people who want me to come and speak at
events and topics i use and the platform
i have and
a sample video but it's the youtube
videos
that create that interest right people
who are watching
my channel know that they're going to an
event or know that their company is
putting on an event and they recommend
me to be a speaker
at the event like i've never met them
ever before in my life they may have
never commented on any of the stuff i
put up
but they're a fan they're a subscriber
they love what i do they're watching
every day
and they recommend me to go to these
events so i generate a lot of
interest in speaking gigs because of the
youtube videos that i put it in
and number five is coaching and again
you'll find just like the info products
that people watch your videos
they they have more questions they need
more help they want
they want the one-on-one time with you
to help them solve whatever problem
they're facing
and so your youtube video is the entry
point right
you know you may share one bit of advice
and people love it and it helps them in
that moment
but then people want the info products
to get to the next step and then they
want your
one-on-one time and and it's the fastest
way to grow right like you can learn a
little bit from me from the videos but
if
if i'm coaching you and you have access
to me
it it's going to dramatically increase
your ability to achieve your goal and
get to where you want to go so much
faster than you're trying to do it
yourself
and you'll find that people want to hire
you as their coach and
i've typically not done it i haven't had
a coaching program because
it's it's very time intensive anything
that i'm a part of
i wanted to be successful i want people
to
see results i don't i don't like having
somebody who i'm working with
who isn't getting the result that
they're looking for it like it stresses
me out
and so i haven't wanted to do coaching
but in coming back from my trip i
realized i really want to have a bigger
impact on the world i really want
to help more entrepreneurs in a
meaningful way and part of that is
seeing these
entrepreneurial businesses take off and
have them impact the world
in their own unique way so i do have a
program called the movement program
and it's for entrepreneurs who really
want to
to do something big right not just to
make money but to change the world and
to make a lot of money
in the process so you can look at my
page it's it's evan carmichael.com
movement and on there you can see how i
lay out my coaching program
so you know as you get better on your
videos and you attract an audience and
you
get more people following you and you
start sharing great advice and you get
people saying
this is amazing you're going to get
people asking you
do you have a coaching program because i
really want to work with you one-on-one
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check out my
training right here below or if you want
to know the five habits that are holding
back your success check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
[Music]
there